the opening scene we are introduced to a
woman named Sabina spielrine who is
suffering from mental instability she is
easily angered and frustrated by the
smallest of things as a result she is
brought to burgosi a renowned
Psychiatric Hospital in Zurich
Switzerland in 1904 it is later revealed
that Sabina is diagnosed with a typical
case of Hysteria and she is going to
begin her treatment under the care of a
Swiss doctor named Carl Young during
their first interaction Dr Carl
positions himself between Sabina and
notices her difficulty in answering
questions characterized by her frequent
stammering the next morning Carl takes a
walk with Sabina in the woods and during
this he discovers that she possesses an
extraordinary ability to anticipate
people's words before they utter them
when asked about this Sabina claims that
she has an inner Angel who communicates
with her in German and helps her predict
things upon hearing this Dr Carl
suggests that her Talent would be
valuable for pursuing a career in
medicine just as she dreams of doing as
the two continue talking Sabina drops
her code on the ground prompting Dr Carl
to pick it up and dust it off using his
walking stick surprisingly this angers
Sabina and she rudely tells him to stop
several days later Carl learns that
Sabina is actually a well-educated woman
with a degree in medicine realizing her
intellect and vitality he grants her the
opportunity to assist him in his
experiments Sabina cannot believe that
she's going to work with such a renowned
scientist so she accepts without any
hesitation the scene then shifts to
Carl's wife Emma who is recently given
birth to a beautiful baby girl excited
about this Carl visits the delivery Ward
to see his newborn however he notices
his wife's unhappiness because she had
hoped to deliver a male child as she had
promised in response Carl console zema
urging her not to entertain such
irrational thoughts amidst these events
Carl and Sabina continue their talking
sessions during which he unveils the
root cause of her condition he explains
the sabina's problems started when her
abusive father humiliated her he used to
punish her on the backside and forced
her to kiss his hands it's actually a
roused Sabina and she began to seek out
any form of humiliation even the act of
Carl striking her coat with his walking
stick earlier had provoked excitement in
her with this strange Revelation Dr Carl
arranges a meeting with Dr Sigmund Freud
a renowned Austrian physician in order
to discuss their patients and to
determine the most effective path
towards their recovery as the doctors
engage in their conversation they begin
to share their views and analyze one
another leading to a lengthy discussion
that stretches on for 13 uninterrupted
hours despite this the boys are not
tired and they decide to meet each other
very soon looks like we're headed for a
Freudian three-way and the egos got
nothing to do with it later Carl meets
Sabina and tells her about his
conversation with Dr Freud as their
conversation unfolds the two discover
their shared interests and become much
closer to each other one day Dr Freud
has to go on an urgent business trip so
he writes a letter to Carl requesting
him to look after a patient named Dr
Otto gross an unstable psychoanalyst
known for his Brilliance and womanizing
tendencies in the letter Dr provides all
the details about Auto including the
peculiar fact that he resorts to biting
when he becomes angry for the sake of
their friendship Carl obliges without
any hesitation he then attends a session
with Otto hoping to use his therapeutic
talking method to help the patient
during this Otto Reveals His lustful
nature boasting about his numerous
Mistresses and the children he has
fathered with them he also advises Carl
to have some extramarital Affairs of his
own according to Otto having multiple
partners keeps a person fit and healthy
while having only one causes a headache
a philosophy still preached today by one
Dr Tate on the following day Sabina
actively assists Carl in his research
and even cracks a few jokes to keep him
fresh she has actually started
recovering from her mental condition on
the other hand Carl's mind wanders back
to Otto's words he finds himself gazing
at Sabina for a while yet somehow
manages to maintain control over his
impulses that evening Carl has another
therapy session with Otto the latter
inquires if he has ever engaged in
intimate relationships with his patients
Carl responds negatively and poses the
same question to Otto in response Otto
reveals that he manipulates his patience
into thinking that their desire to not
have intercourse with him is an illness
he uses this technique on all the women
he meets and it works almost every time
Otto boasts that he has actually had
intercourse with more than 100 women the
next morning Carl meets Sabina at a park
and they begin talking about intercourse
Sabina reveals that she has no sexual
experience suggesting that this may be a
contributing factor to her feelings of
depression and anxiety hence she would
like to gain such an experience right
away when the doctor hesitates Sabina
takes the initiative and kisses him
unexpectedly she then invites Carl to
her place later that evening so that
they can have passionate intercourse
later during the therapy session Otto
urges Carl to give in and perform erotic
acts on Sabina since she wants it he
should give it to her however Carl
remains Resolute in his decision he
doesn't want to betray his wife and also
acknowledges the taboo of becoming
involved with a patient but as the
persuasive Auto continues narrating some
of his romantic encounters Carl's
resolve starts weakening he eventually
succumbs to his desires when the crazy
Otto claps a worker in the open field
unable to control himself anymore Carl
rushes to sabina's place and ends up
getting intimate with her this marks the
beginning of their Affair and over time
they engage in even more vigorous acts
which include bondage and spanking one
day Emma surprises Carl with a boat
adorned with red sails knowing it is
something he has always wanted she
regards him as the best man in the world
and mentions that he deserves everything
he desires witnessing his wife's love
and Trust Carl realizes that he is
betraying her as a result he visits
Sabina at her residence and confesses
that they should terminate their Affair
at once however she persuades him to
continue their relationship urging him
to punish her just like the way her
father used to do in the next scene Dr
Freud returns from the business trip and
meets with Carl resuming their
discussions about their respective
theories of psychoanalysis however they
frequently find themselves ourselves at
odds leading to a strain in their
friendship as the discussion starts
heating up Freud brings up a rumor that
Carl has taken one of his patients as a
mistress and is having coitus with her
however the latter firmly denies that
accusation he claims that he is simply
treating the woman with a close eye and
a spanking here and there but mostly a
close eye after the meeting ends Carl
realizes that he can no longer conceal
his affair so he decides to end his
secret relationship with Sabina leaving
her heartbroken and devastated a few
days later an enraged Sabine storms into
Carl's office and accuses him of
informing her mother about their affair
she calls him a betrayer and an idiot
however in response Carl reveals that
her mother was already aware of the
relationship due to an anonymous letter
she had received he informs Sabina that
he will now only treat her as his
patient disregarding their previous
connection this further infuriates
Sabina leading her to grab a knife and
cut Carl's face before storming out
later on she writes a letter to Dr Freud
requesting a meeting to discuss the
affair between herself and Carl after
reading her letter Freud writes a
correspondence to Carl to inquire about
the truth of the matter but Carl denies
any involvement he says that Sabina is
actually trying to destroy his life by
spreading false rumors about him okay
Google what theory is Carl Jung best
known for
gaslighting due to their close
friendship Freud believes it right away
and he sends a letter to Sabina in it he
mentions that he cannot meet her at the
moment as he is busy with work Freud
also suggests that they resolve their
issues without his intervention
overwhelmed by the circumstances Sabina
visits Carl's office once again only to
discover that he is leaving the hospital
it turns out that he is traveling to the
United States to take part in a major
conference enraged Sabina chastises Carl
for lying to Freud about their affair
she demands that he read a letter to
Freud confessing the truth about their
relationship Sabina also reminds Carl
that she could have publicly harmed his
reputation but chose not to hearing all
this Carl ultimately obliges and sends a
letter to his Austrian friend revealing
the full extent of the truth when Freud
goes through the letter he feels
betrayed but not shocked he simply
writes a letter to Sabina offering his
apologies and expressing admiration for
her way to resolve the conflict the
scene then cuts to a few years later
when Sabina travels to Carl's house in
Switzerland in order to collaborate on
her dissert as they work together they
are reminded of their lustful past where
they had intercourse in numerous
locations like Carl's bedroom the mental
ward inside of the unconscious mind and
even a boat so they decide to add
another memory to the list by having
coitus again afterwards Sabina shares
her decision to leave Zurich after
completing her graduation and relocate
to Vienna this makes Carl emotional and
he requests that she not go but Sabina
doesn't change her mind two more years
pass and Sabina now a qualified
psychiatrist is in Vienna where she
meets with Freud during their discussion
on psychoanalysis Sabina expresses that
she is on Freud's side but she also
emphasizes the importance of coexistence
between Freud and Carl for the continued
development of psychoanalysis however
Freud doesn't appear to be interested in
reconciling with Carl they have grown so
distant that they don't even want to see
each other's faces a year later Sabina
pays a visit to Emma at her residence
Sabina is now married to a Russian
doctor and she is expecting a child with
the couple expressing a preference for a
baby girl as they engage in conversation
Emma reveals that Carl's mental state
has been deteriorating since he ended
ties with Freud as a result she asks
Sabina to talk to him on the other hand
we see Carl quietly sitting by a
peaceful River it is revealed that he
has distanced himself from his research
work and is no longer productive shortly
after Sabina approaches him and
initiates a conversation Carl reveals
that he has been plagued by apocalyptic
dreams that prevent him from sleeping
sometimes he sees that the entire city
is being ravaged by a flood a flood so
gigantic that it can destroy the entire
world Sabina finds the conversation
boring so she quickly changes the topic
and informs him that she is returning to
Russia with her husband she then
inquires about his new mistress and Carl
responds by stating that her name is
Tony and that she Bears resemblance to
Sabina he says that Tony reminds him of
the good times he spent with Sabina Carl
further admits that his love for Sabina
has contributed to his personal growth
but acknowledges that there is nothing
he can do to change the situation after
the conversation Sabina gets on a
carriage and leaves the city while Carl
is still lost in his in the film's
closing remarks the Destinies of the
four analysts are disclosed it is
mentioned that Otto tragically died from
starvation in Berlin in 1920. Freud
after being forced out of Vienna by the
Nazis passed away from cancer in London
in 1939. Sabina having trained numerous
analysts in the Soviet Union suffered a
devastating fate along with her two
daughters as they were shot by the Nazis
in 1942. meanwhile Carl overcame a
nervous breakdown and went on to achieve
recognition as the best psychologist in
the world before his death in 1961.
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on the notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching